well alright thank you very much great
to see everybody nice to be part of the
famous people's Club where we pretend to
know each other and have seen each
other's work it's just part of it it
requires it
oh you how are you I'm good lady all
right good evening and welcome to the
10th annual Governor's Awards has it
really been just ten years yes yes ten
years have flown by haven't they yes it
was all the way back in 2008 when just a
few dozen of us got together at round
tables across the street at the
Roosevelt Hotel decided to give out the
governor's awards a great honorees and
with a pitcher of margaritas we just sat
and watched film clips on VHS my lord
wasn't that oh it's a magic night now
look how it's grown tonight is unlike
any other night in this our company town
and even in the whole of the Arts and
Sciences of motion pictures because
together we are celebrating without
anyone being nervous about who is going
to win
everybody wins tonight
the only competition comes afterwards
and the fight to guess the first bird
scooter to ride home arguments over
who's lift is that and that's my uber
get out of my er bruh there's gonna be
some losers there so just make your
peace with that right away our honorees
tonight I'll demonstrate the diversity
of our community not just in where they
came from or what they overcome to get
here but in the incredible range of
talents and what they do individually
they are already legends one great actor
actress successively Tyson
to producers Cathy Kennedy and Frank
Marshall who often have to point out to
people I'm Frank please she's cat they
get mistaken for each other all the time
we have a publicist
Marvin levy
[Music]
and a composer not just of his films but
of much of our lives Lalo Schifrin
they are all world-renowned contributors
of that mosaic that is our film family
each is what we all aspire to be
storytellers in their own right so just
step back and widen the lens and think
about the films that get made and how
and why and share and the truth that
everyone in our community be it a writer
or director or a cinematographer a
composer of publicist or producer they
all have a hand in how the story gets
told how it gets seen it takes a canny
eye and a dulcet voice it takes a supple
imagination and it takes a ton of work
to tell the stories that cry out to be
told and our honorees tonight have set
the very highest standards of how to do
all that with a conviction in their
creativity and the excellence in the
repeated execution none more so than a
pioneer and fittingly the first
publicist in the Academy history to
receive an honorary Oscar ladies and
gentlemen Marvin levy
or as we have called them again and
again a giant of a man
Marvin began his remarkable journey
working for MGM in New York City before
joining Columbia Pictures here in
Hollywood where he guided the
advertising for films from the deep -
Kramer vs Kramer his work for the 1977
film Close Encounters of the Third Kind
was the beginning of a four decade long
and continuing partnership with Steven
Spielberg who relied on Marvin to
introduce America to characters and
themes as heavy and as harrowing as ET
and Schindler's List and Saving Private
Ryan and Lincoln now all those movies
are pretty damn good but I don't think
any of us in this room would have
bothered seeing them without the efforts
of Marvin levy
on every assignment the hits and the
ones that are not so much two hits
Marvin faces a daunting challenge after
years of the writers of the directors
and the actors pouring their sweat
equity into a film and without giving
too much away
Marvin levy has to make the American
public want to give up their precious
time and their hard-earned cash to go
see it a marketing department can make
you aware of a title but it takes
something of a storyteller to get an
honest hooked on the story without
giving away the story but that's what
Marvin levy does that's his magic the
man whose first brushstroke on the blank
canvas can seduce us making us just have
to see the rest of the masterpiece and
God willing see it in a theater near you
because film struck is gone folks it's
gone gone wow that was a great reaction
now
dr. Marvin if you've worked for Marvin
mmm you have been told what to say well
is it your Hinton you were given hints
of what to say but you are told what not
to say pay attention to both those
conversations you have with Marvin it
will ease your work and it will serve
the motion-picture you might never hear
his name but you do know his work
artists everywhere might never have met
Marvin levy but when one of their films
captures the hearts of the captive
audience that he helps deliver he moved
mountains to help make it so ladies and
gentlemen it's time for everyone to hear
Marvin levy story by way of this VHS
clip package